[Music]
in pale for everything news submitted by
timmy turner scientists are working on a
pill for loneliness
so you mean you take the pill and then
you get imaginary friends that call esta
see I was thinking like the pill is your
friend
step on in the powder I mean you don't
step on your friends yeah can't step on
your friends to get ahead or you put in
water and becomes a big fluffy dinosaur
oh the sea monk yells yeah yeah no the
sea monkeys are the little shrimp the
black shrimp right yeah these are like
copings
remember you put in water and we just
turn into ice like a dinosaur oh yeah
I didn't like the texture of it after it
turned big yes all these weird it was
like as big as you thought
yeah nice very good very good
so what happened
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's the worst talk in the world I
thought I was supposed to be how you use
it no no misdirection yeah yeah yeah set
the size of the boat it's how much you
come that's why Tyco is really strong
I'm coming out a good amount right yeah
oh yeah go to his channel it's there go
to his channel there's a video oh we
were having dinner did yeah he we were
all having dinner and this is the
conversation he busted in my mouth and
there was so much calm that I was like
and then a little bit came out because I
couldn't hold it all in yeah hey Tycho
was like oh yeah
so cute he was younger than he is now so
he really didn't know what's that vlog
on my channel yeah it was funny
literally Panza here man he goes mama
took a lotta car alright so this story
here
dr. Stephanie Casio sorry BAM I'm grease
okay so she is a director your greasy
fries what is happening he's like I'm
Gracie
dr. Stephanie Patsy offal okay I did it
better the second time so she's a
director of the brain dynamics lab at
the University of Chicago Pritzker
School of Medicine sounds like a fake
school yeah so her and her husband have
been researching loneliness and like the
way it affects your brain like how your
brain changes when you're feeling lonely
and so she says that like the so
recently her husband passed oh she got
lonely yeah so she was saying like you
know the best example of like I'm living
proof of the research that we've been
conducting through all these years so
she said that she disagrees when people
they end up associating loneliness being
or like physical pain being worse than
what loneliness feels because she was
like honestly I don't think so my
physical pain could be like surpass but
it's still not as much as my loneliness
so she totally gets it now that her
husband has passed so anyway so she's
saying that all their research together
that they she and her husband were
working on creating a pill that can
reduce the alarm signals in the brain
that can result from people feeling
lonely to make them better equipped to
reach outwards rather than falling
inwards and so into social isolation we
her and her husband were working on this
pill to get rid of loneliness and then
he died and now she's
yeah I know that iron ringing what a
great story this could be a movie yeah
because that's like a superhero's like
motivation you know like I was gonna do
this in daylight somebody died and they
like I gotta do something now
he studied yes or her husband um was a
neuroscientist who studied social pain
social pain yeah that [ __ ] is real man
you actually had a book called
loneliness my there were some lonely
[ __ ] you know lonely people do
read so they're saying that they got me
more to talk to yeah you try that you
think you're gonna figure it out by
reading all those books but no I mean
I'm talking about a friend of mine you
remind me of that kid from that [ __ ]
neverending story where he's like wow
like he's in the [ __ ] flying dog and
[ __ ] yeah yeah what was that thing never
any story it was a dog it was an actual
dog dog dragon I don't know dog a Flying
Dog
yeah anyway so here they're saying that
loneliness elevates the risk of
developing a range of disorders
including cardiovascular disease your
generative disease cognitive decline and
metastatic cancer and it also weakens
the immune system making us more
susceptible to infections and if it's
left unattended even situational
loneliness can hasta Phi into a fixed
state that changes brain structure and
processes man humans are so social cuz
it sounds like the same [ __ ] that you go
through when you're depressed like
what's the difference
I think loneliness can trigger
depression yeah cuz it sounds like the
same just symptom and similar symptoms
but it's a but loneliness like you say
it can trigger depression and they've
even done this study with animals so
they'll take like like monkeys who are
used to be in a social group and they
put them by themselves and then just by
them being by themselves and not having
an interaction with other monkeys or
cortisol levels go high and then they
start having power problems among
problems but get ulcers there's like
all kinds and you just see this monkey
just deteriorate and the minute they put
him back with his friends like this guy
slowly starts to recover again even hair
quality you know who don't give a [ __ ]
snakes they don't give a [ __ ] I think I
could handle loneliness over loss though
like loss hurts yeah cuz that's like
your husband dies like you had a partner
and you weren't lonely and then now you
know what it feels like and they lost it
and any temporary loneliness is
different from chronic loneliness yeah
they're talking more here about like
chronic like you've been lonely you
alone or maybe you shouldn't have such a
bad personality so they're saying that
unlike introverted
you just lived in the wrong neighborhood
reading about my friend you would've
easily had friends if you grew up where
we did
well that's I'm saying okay so like just
to play devil's advocate and [ __ ] like
that [ __ ] Boyet part of me feels like
it's your fault if you're lonely because
you're an ass no no I'm not that he's
gonna say I mean if what if they weren't
spending all this time you know what if
she doesn't we took a break from
spending all this time working on this
pail and actually you know like just
went and played checkers with a friend
wouldn't that cure loneliness too she's
a researcher the pill helps them go
please yeah yeah also and they'd put you
more in a move that makes you want to go
and so so oh I see it's not the remedy
for it but it's it's it's the motivator
yes relieve the severe symptoms like
that happened like because your brain
changes chemically like when you are
experiencing loneliness I mean born or
in a depressed state what ends up
happening is they do things to make them
even more depressed instead of the
opposite and that's why they're in a
depressed state because everyone's like
it's like that it there but their minds
just in that stage it goes into more
depression so I think it's the same case
of loneliness right like there's a
they're not reaching out they're not
going out they can't be proactive they
can't do anything on their own mm-hm and
they're researchers so they're not only
there studying lonely people and
practicing on lonely people right so
they have so they
she's alone she's lonely now cuz her
husband died she was lonely now but
before I was like study hundreds or
thousands of other lonely people with
her eyes she's not chronically lonely
they're saying that unlike depression
and anxiety loneliness has no recognized
clinical form and there's no available
diagnosis or treatment for feeling
chronically isolated so that's why like
she's they've been researching this in
so she had trials where they used a
certain type of steroid to relieve the
social social isolation symptoms and it
they found that it did counteract
loneliness inspired biological changes
in the brain but it was without the side
effects of other antidepressants such as
insomnia and nausea so cool like
hopefully her research I'm curious
because sometimes you can feel more
lonely in a group of people than when
you're alone so you know what they're
saying so the the loneliness aspect of
it is because people don't feel like
they have a purpose in life like a sense
of purpose or like they're not really
nection they're not connected to
something bigger than themselves so some
of the ways to to combat the feeling of
no loneliness is to go like volunteer in
an organization or in some type of
movement or even a religious group and
it gives you a sense of taking part in
something larger than yourself yeah join
a cult or something do something
productive as I'm thinking like you
belong yeah yeah now I got that I think
the need for humans to belong is so
[ __ ] important right that sometimes
people just [ __ ] do it because of the
group not because of any other reason
like yeah you guys jump off a bridge I'm
jumping too can I have the passwords
here channels you know it's crazy I was
thinking like how alright if we were
like hunter-gatherers right and it's
like if you're lonely or you just it's
hard to be lonely because you'll be in
your hut and we'll be like hey why are
you always in your hunt let's go [ __ ]
fish you see each other every day we
doesn't you you see yet there's no way
out of it right but today it's so
[ __ ] easy to be in a big city full of
people but you
here apartment you just go to work you
come back or whatever and you feel so
alone with all kinds of people around
you 24/7 right yeah because you know
what's happening to there they're
talking about it in this article where
nowadays like the more society
progresses like with technology the less
we have to interact face-to-face so now
instead of like you know if you're
waiting for a friend at a restaurant
instead of making small talk with
strangers you immediately just pull out
yourself from them easier rather than
having human interaction right with
people so it's it's making loneliness
become an epidemic according to this
researcher it's just easier to be lonely
yeah yeah they make it convenient I
believe it mm-hmm it's easier than
trying to talk to somebody and risk them
being like yeah unless you're sitting at
the bar and then everyone it's like down
the talk yeah they're saying that at the
World Economic Forum in Switzerland last
month world leaders were told that 40%
of those under the age of 25 globally
say that they feel lonely hmm wait how
much percent forty almost half of the
world is Rory's under twenty five people
are anybody wanted five it makes sense
cuz that's the time where you like you
haven't really found your purpose or
like you're sure like your path yeah
you're kind of still figuring it out and
you feel like you're supposed to haven't
figured out why you don't and you're
like who am i what am i doing with my
life yeah yeah yeah I don't think I ever
felt lonely no yeah I mean but we're
special bro we're different
extroverts no well cuz I I like being
alone sometimes okay long alone that
doesn't make me feel lonely yeah
same that's what I was saying like I
feel like more lonely in a group of
people sometimes than I do at home
because like left out yeah like in a
group of people sometimes it feels like
they all know what they're doing and
they all like have their thing and just
like I feel like you're an expert on
loneliness how does that feel like I
don't know you're talking about
friend but my friend would like a lot of
friends home alone because there's like
activities to do it you don't feel
lonely in but then you're around a group
of people and it's like oh they're all
gelling and you're like over here and
your voice is from you in those
situations I end up feeling like I I
want to learn and be part of the group
instead of feeling like the mo movie
here yeah yeah like I don't know if I'm
in a group situation where I don't know
what's happening I'm just like hey I'll
pull one of them and be like hey how do
we do this thing that everyone's doing
cuz I don't know what's happening do you
know what's happening you know once I
find out that they're like I don't know
either I'm just following everyone I'm
like cool I feel I think that becoming
more secure with yourself so if you're
not used to being around people and then
you're around people it's like oh I
don't know what to do with my hands and
stuff and then after a while then you
become work oh this is how it works and
operates but if you're used to spending
a lot of time alone sometimes you could
feel more lonely if you're in a group of
friends a loser dude I know she's not my
friend anymore I want to feel lonely
okay you've never felt it yeah I want to
feel it
[Music]
[Music]